>>> IN OUR HEALTH LEAD, A BRAND
NEW STUDY RELEASED THIS
AFTERNOON SHOWS THAT AN
ESTIMATED 7.5 MILLION PEOPLE,
7.5 MILLION, ARE MISDIAGNOSED
EVERY YEAR AT EMERGENCY ROOMS
ACROSS THE UNITED STATES.
I UNFORTUNATELY KNOW ALL TOO
WELL ABOUT THE COST OF
MISDIAGNOSIS.
ABOUT A YEAR AGO MY THEN
14-YEAR-OLD DAUGHTER ALICE
ALMOST DIED AS A RESULT.
AND THIS IS NOT A STORY I WOULD
NORMALLY SHARE WITH A MASS
AUDIENCE.
BUT ALICE'S EXPERIENCE IS ONE
THAT ALICE BELIEVES CAN HELP
OTHERS BECAUSE HER ORDEAL WAS
ENTIRELY PREVENTABLE.
LAST NOVEMBER, 2021, ALICE
BECAME SICK WITH APPENDICITIS.
BUT THE DOCTORS MISDIAGNOSED
WHAT SHE HAD BECAUSE HER
SYMPTOMS WERE NOT COMPLETELY
STANDARD ONES FOR APPENDICITIS.
ULTIMATELY, WE LEARNED THAT
WHILE THEY WERE TREATING HER FOR
A VIRAL INFECTION INSTEAD HER
APPENDIX HAD ACTUALLY PERFORATED
AND TOXIC FLUID WAS SEEPING OUT
AND POISONING HER INTERNAL
ORGANS.
HER BODY STARTED GOING INTO
WHAT'S CALLED HYPOVALEMIC SHOCK,
MEANING HER HEART WAS UNABLE TO
PUMP ENOUGH BLOOD TO ALL OF HER
ORGANS, WHICH CAUSES ORGAN
FAILURE.
AND AS MY FAMILY LEARNED THE
HARD WAY, THIS SPECIFIC
APPENDICITIS MISDIAGNOSIS, IT'S
REALLY NOT ALL THAT UNCOMMON.
APPENDICITIS DOES NOT ALWAYS
PRESENT A STANDARD WAY.
WHICH MEANS THAT THIS SPECIFIC
MISDIAGNOSIS HAPPENS TOO OFTEN
AND SOMETIMES TO FAR MORE TRAGIC
RESULTS.
ALICE HAS RECOVERED THANKFULLY.
SHE IS NOW STRONGER AND FITTER
THAN EVER.
BUT THIS WAS OBVIOUSLY A
HORRIFIC TRAUMA, PHYSICAL AND
OTHERWISE.
ALICE AND MY WIFE JENNIFER ARE
NOW TRYING TO CHANGE HOW DOCTORS
RULE OUT APPENDICITIS.
WE ASKED CNN'S CHIEF MEDICAL
CORRESPONDENT DR. SANJAY GUPTA
TO TAKE A LOOK AT WHAT ALICE
WENT THROUGH AND HOW THIS CAN BE
PREVENTED FOR ANYONE ELSE.
>> I WAS SO TIRED.
I WOULD SLEEP THROUGH THE WHOLE
DAY AND MY STOMACH WAS -- HURT
SO BAD.
I'VE NEVER BEEN IN THAT AMOUNT
OF EXTREME PAIN BEFORE.
THAT WAS THE SCARIEST THING I'VE
EVER SEEN.
BECAUSE IT WAS JUST -- THE LIFE
WAS JUST LEAVING HER.
AND I JUST THOUGHT THIS IS --
WHAT IS WRONG -- WHY IS HER SKIN
SO GREEN AND WHY ARE HER HANDS
AND FEET FREEZING?
>> I MEAN, YOU REALLY THOUGHT
THAT ALICE MIGHT DIE.
>> I ABSOLUTELY DON'T LIKE TO
THINK THAT SHE COULD HAVE DIED,
BUT 100% I WAS STARTING TO
THINK.
>> Reporter: JENNIFER AND MY
COLLEAGUE JAKE TAPPER ARE
15-YEAR-OLD ALICE'S PARENTS.
THEY ALL WANTED TO SHARE THEIR
STORY AS A CAUTIONARY TALE AND
TO SHED LIGHT ON HOW SOMETHING
SO COMMON, SO TREATABLE COULD GO
SO TERRIBLY WRONG.
>> I STARTED THROWING UP ON A
SATURDAY MORNING, AND I GOT
REALLY SICK.
I WAS JUST NOT GETTING BETTER.
SO MY PARENTS TOOK ME TO GO INTO
THE HOSPITAL.
>> Reporter: MOST LIKELY
DIAGNOSIS AT THE TIME, STOMACH
PAINS, POSSIBLE FOOD POISONING,
GASTROENTERITIS.
JENNIFER WAS PARTICULARLY
WORRIED ABOUT APPENDICITIS.
>> I SAID -- THIS IS ON MONDAY.
AND I SAID WHY DON'T YOU JUST
GIVE HER A SONOGRAM.
SHE HAS SO MUCH GOING ON DOWN
THERE, SHE'S IN SO MUCH PAIN.
LET'S JUST SEE WHAT IT IS
BECAUSE WE DON'T KNOW.
AND THEY LOOKED AT ME AND THE
DOCTOR SAID, "THAT DATA'S NOT
NEEDED."
>> THAT DATA'S NOT NEEDED.
>> WE DON'T NEED THAT DATA.
>> Reporter: DATA.
EVIDENCE.
AND ONE MORE CRITICAL
INGREDIENT.
JUDGMENT.
IT'S WHAT DOCTORS USE TO TRY AND
MAKE DECISIONS.
FOR EXAMPLE, PAIN IN THE RIGHT
LOWER BELLY IS CONSIDERED ONE OF
THE MOST COMMON SYMPTOMS OF
APPENDICITIS.
AND YET LESS THAN HALF OF ALL
PEOPLE WITH APPENDICITIS HAVE
THE CLASSIC PATTERN.
>> WHERE WERE YOU EXPERIENCING
THE PAIN?
>> I HAD PAIN ALL OVER MY
ABDOMEN INSTEAD OF JUST MY RIGHT
QUADRANT.
THE WAY THAT THEY RULED OUT
APPENDICITIS WAS A JUMP TEST.
I WAS ASKED TO JUMP, AND I WAS
ABLE TO MAYBE GET ONE INCH OFF
THE GROUND.
AND JUST THAT RULED OUT
APPENDICITIS FOR ALL THE
DOCTORS.
AND THAT'S WHEN THEY JUST
DECLARED IT WAS A VIRAL
INFECTION.
>> BUT --
>> Reporter: DR. PRASHAN MAHAJAN
HEADS THE PEDIATRIC EMERGENCY
MEDICINE DEPARTMENT AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF MICHIGAN.
HE SAYS MISDIAGNOSIS CAN OCCUR
IN PART BECAUSE OF DIAGNOSTIC
MOMENTUM.
>> YOU ANCHOR YOURSELF ON THAT
PARTICULAR DIAGNOSIS AND IT IS
POSSIBLE IN SOME INSTANCES THAT
IT IS TAKING YOU AWAY FROM THE
CONDITION THAT THE PATIENT HAS.
>> Reporter: IT WAS IN PART THAT
DIAGNOSTIC MOMENTUM THAT LED TO
THE DOCTORS MISSING THE EARLY
SIGNS OF APPENDICITIS IN ALICE.
EVERY YEAR ROUGHLY 25,000
CHILDREN DEVELOP APPENDICITIS,
AND ACCORDING TO THE STUDY
PUBLISHED IN 2020 BY DR.
MAHAJAN, ROUGHLY 5% OF THE TIME,
THAT'S 1,000 TIMES A YEAR, THE
STORY MIRRORS THE STORY OF WHAT
HAPPENED TO ALICE TAPPER NEXT.
>> WE WENT INTO THE HOSPITAL,
AND WE JUST ASSUMED THE DOCTORS
KNEW WHAT THEY WERE TALKING
ABOUT.
THEY KIND OF BACKED INTO A
DIAGNOSIS OF A VIRAL INFECTION.
AND JANET AND I WOULD SAY ARE
YOU SURE IT'S NOT APPENDICITIS?
BECAUSE HER PEDIATRICIAN THINKS
IT MIGHT BE.
IS THERE SOME REASON WE CAN'T
GIVE HER ANTIBIOTICS?
GET AN X-RAY OR A SCAN?
>> WE SEE THE CHILD EVERY DAY.
SO I KNEW HER SKIN COLORING WAS
DIFFERENT.
I KNEW HER BELLY WAS DISTENDED
EVEN THOUGH SHE'S A
SMALLER-FRAMED CHILD.
THOSE ARE THE THINGS WE KEPT
SAYING.
>> Reporter: IN FACT, MORE THAN
THREE EXCRUCIATING DAYS PASSED
IN THE HOSPITAL WITHOUT MUCH
MORE THAN PAIN RELIEVERS BEFORE
THE TAPPER FAMILY WAS FINALLY
ABLE TO GET SOME ANSWERS.
>> I'M A JOURNALIST.
SO I WAS ABLE TO GET THE NUMBER
OF THE ADMINISTRATOR, FIGURE IT
OUT.
AND THEY TOOK THE CALL AND THEY
TOOK ACTION.
BUT MOST PEOPLE WOULDN'T HAVE
BEEN ABLE TO DO THAT.
WE RECOGNIZE WE HAVE THIS
PRIVILEGE.
>> WE GOT AN X-RAY AND IT SHOWED
THAT I HAD SOMETHING GOING ON IN
MY APPENDIX.
SO AFTER WE GOT A SONOGRAM THEY
WERE LIKE WE NEED TO RUSH YOU
INTO SURGERY AFTER THIS.
>> Reporter: BUT BY THEN ALICE
HAD WORSENED.
DRAMATICALLY.
THE REASON SHE HAD SUFFERED SUCH
WIDESPREAD PAIN WAS BECAUSE HER
APPENDIX HAD ALREADY RUPTURED,
LEADING TO SEVERE INFECTION AND
SEPSIS.
AN APPENDECTOMY IS ONE OF THE
MOST COMMON PEDIATRIC OPERATIONS
PERFORMED.
TYPICALLY, IT LASTS FOR ABOUT AN
HOUR AND THE RECOVERY TAKES A
FEW WEEKS.
IN ALICE'S CASE, HOWEVER, THE
OPERATION COULDN'T EVEN BE DONE
BECAUSE HER ABDOMINAL CAVITY WAS
NOW FILLED WITH INFECTED FLUID.
>> I HAD TO GET TWO LIPOSCOPIC
DRAINS AT FIRST.
AND THEN AFTER THEY DISCHARGED
ME AND SENT ME HOME I WENT BACK
TO THE HOSPITAL BECAUSE I STILL
WASN'T FEELING ABOUT THOR AND
THEY HAD TO PUT ANOTHER
LIPOSCOPIC DRAIN IN ME.
I ENDED UP GETTING MY APPENDIX
OUT 12 WEEKS LATER, IN MARCH.
>> WHAT WAS YOUR LIFE LIKE
DURING THOSE 12 WEEKS?
>> I HAD LOST SO MUCH WEIGHT
FROM BEING HOSPITALIZED THAT I
WAS JUST STRUGGLING TO EAT AND
ABLE TO FUNCTION.
I HAD TROUBLE GOING TO SCHOOL.
I WOULD GET SO TIRED AND MAKE MY
MOM PICK ME UP EARLY.
>> Reporter: MONTHS OF HER LIFE
LOST.
SO MUCH OF THAT ENTIRELY
PREVENTABLE.
>> I THINK A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE
GOING TO WATCH THIS AND FRANKLY
BE WORRIED.
IS THERE A LESSON HERE, DO YOU
THINK?
>> THIS ISN'T A TIME TO BE
POLITE WHEN YOU'RE IN THE
HOSPITAL.
YOU MUST DEFEND YOUR CHILD, AND
YOU'RE -- LISTENING TO PARENTS
IS PROBABLY THE MOST IMPORTANT
THING DOCTORS AND HOSPITALS CAN
DO.
>> THIS COULD HAVE HAPPENED TO
ANY CHILD AT ANY HOSPITAL IN THE
UNITED STATES BECAUSE DOCTORS
ARE NOT SUFFICIENTLY AWARE OF
HOW OFTEN IT IS THAT
APPENDICITIS DOES NOT PRESENT IN
A STANDARD WAY.
>> Reporter: IT'S BEEN NINE
MONTHS SINCE ALICE TAPPER
FINALLY GOT HER APPENDECTOMY.
AND AFTER A PARTICULARLY DARK
TIME SHE IS ONCE AGAIN ALLOWING
HERSELF TO START DREAMING ABOUT
THE FUTURE.
BUT NOW SHE HAS A NEW MISSION AS
WELL.
>> I WANT TO ROW IN COLLEGE AND
MAYBE STUDY ZOOLOGY.
I JUST LOVE HOW MY LIFE IS
TURNING OUT.
I THINK THAT IT WAS A REALLY --
I WISH IT NEVER HAPPENED TO ME,
OBVIOUSLY.
BUT I THINK IT WAS A REALLY
IMPORTANT LEARNING EXPERIENCE
FOR ME.
I WANT OTHER KIDS TO KNOW THAT
THEY NEED TO ADVOCATE FOR
THEMSELVES.
>> SO SANJAY, YOU'RE NOT ONLY A
DAD, YOU'RE A DOCTOR WHO WORKS
AT A MAJOR HOSPITAL.
I CAN TELL YOU FIRSTHAND HOW
FRUSTRATING THIS WAS FOR ME AND
JENNIFER.
SO AS A PARENT WHEN YOU KNOW
SOMETHING IS WRONG WITH YOUR KID
HOW CAN YOU REALLY GET YOUR
DOCTOR'S ATTENTION IF YOU FEEL
THEY'RE NOT LISTENING AND NOT
TAKING SUFFICIENTLY SERIOUSLY
WHAT YOU'RE TELLING THEM?
>> YEAH.
WELL, FIRST, JAKE, I WANT TO SAY
THAT I'M SORRY.
JUST I SAW ALL THAT YOU -- ALL
THAT ALICE AND ALL OF YOU WENT
THROUGH.
AND JUST AS A FELLOW HUMAN I
JUST WANT TO SAY I'M SORRY.
I READ THOSE MEDICAL RECORDS.
THERE WAS HUNDREDS OF PAGES.
IT WAS HARD TO BELIEVE WHAT I
WAS READING, THAT SORT OF
NIGHTMARE SCENARIO THAT WAS
UNFOLDING.
AND I JUST WANTED TO SAY I'M SO
SORRY YOU GUYS WENT THROUGH
THAT.
LOOK, I LEARNED A LOT WHILE
LOOKING INTO THIS, JAKE.
I THINK ONE OF THE THINGS
JENNIFER SAID NEAR THE END,
REALLY BEING THE ADVOCATE,
UNDERSTANDING THAT PARENTS KNOW
THEIR CHILDREN BETTER THAN
ANYONE, AND REALLY FOCUSING ON
WHAT TENDS TO BE ONE OF THE MOST
COMMON REASONS FOR MISDIAGNOSIS,
WHICH IS IF SYMPTOMS ARE
ATYPICAL AT ALL.
IT TENDS TO THROW OFF MAYBE THE
OBVIOUS SIGNS IN THIS CASE OF
APPENDICITIS.
THERE'S A NEW STUDY THAT CAME
OUT TODAY SHOWING THERE'S 130
MILLION E.R. VISITS EVERY YEAR
AND ABOUT 5% TO 6% OF THE TIME
THERE'S A MISDIAGNOSIS.
2% OF THE TIME IT CAN LEAD TO
ADVERSE SIDE EFFECTS.
AND ABOUT .3% OF THE TIME THEY
CAN BE VERY SERIOUS SIDE
EFFECTS, EVEN DEATH.
SO THAT DOES HAPPEN.
BUT I THINK IT'S T